I want to show you a little bit more
from that Elon Musk interview with the
Babylon B guys a couple days ago because
I think he really nailed it here
if you've got people on the fringes on
both sides upset then you're doing
something right right yeah but when it
comes to lgbtq and Q Anon right so
Taylor Swift upset
um I was thinking that's why I think you
know things go full circle
lgbtq Anon
you could probably get me in trouble if
you like well probably will
you were saying
I just love that because I'm telling you
this guy is just telling you what he
thinks in real time lgbtq Anon that'll
probably get me in trouble like that's
the thing what we want to stop right now
are the crazies on both sides and the
reason that I focus more on the crazies
of the left is it's the crazies of the
left that are fueling The Crazies of the
right there is nobody like generally
speaking on the right who is like a you
know like of true racist and that they
want people to have different laws or a
true homophobe and that they want to
jail gaze or whatever anything is what
they but the radicals on the left have
gone so crazy and because it's pushed
through mainstream and everything else
you're starting to empower the radicals
on the right and that is a problem that
really is a problem
foreign
[Music]